foreign
Catherine's with us in Richmond Virginia
hi Catherine how are you
how are you doing better than I deserve
what's up
so um
I am in a business with my family
my grandmother wanted to give to me and
my seven cousins a real estate business
where we bought different houses and
this happened about 10 years ago
um she gifted it to us when I was in
college my brother runs it
he um is in charge of all the finances
and everything and I want out I don't
know anything that's going on with the
business
um I don't know why
um
why do you not know I'm well
because at the time I was I was 20 I
didn't ask a lot of questions how old
are you now
I'm 30. 30. okay well that's 10 years
ago you had 10 years to get caught up to
speed why do you not know right um well
actually I I was working at a real
estate right after college I was working
at Real Estate Management business and I
got the owner to kind of help me
communicate with my
um with my other my cousins and my
brother about the situation and
um I we got in a fight about it and
um
what was the fight about
you asked for information on the
business on the business that you owned
part of and he didn't want to tell you
I asked for the income expense
statements
um I tried to say you know like this is
a business not like a family matter but
he tried to make it you know an
emotional Family Matter
um how long ago was that you don't
you don't how long ago was that
that was
so what'd you do you just got a little
quiet Mouse and sat there for seven
years on your angst I did I tried to yes
I did okay so what are you gonna do now
I tried to get my grandma involved what
are you gonna do now I don't know that's
why I'm why I'm calling the show okay
so you don't know how to get out
procedurally
or are you trying to ask for emotional
advice on this
uh procedurally and how to communicate
well about you know I'm a teacher I
don't know anything about business
really
or how to run a business or about real
estate I mean my husband and I own a
house but
um I don't know anything about LLC or
okay I I had you talked to your brother
now otherwise
yes
for like Christmas you'll see
yes and you just don't say anything you
just he just has bullied his way and put
you in the corner
Blossom had a conversation with him
about it was a year ago on a family trip
um I was like Hey like how's this going
um is there any chance that I could you
know see the financials that we could
have this conversation again
um and have it not be an emotional thing
but as a co-business owner and as like a
partner in this LLC all together
um I need to you know I'm really busy he
owns another business local business and
um he told me about your brother's a
turd all right hold on a minute you
didn't put any money into this your
grandmother funded all of it and handed
it to you and your cousins
yes how much is all of this worth do you
guess
um there's about four or five
hundred thousand they're probably worth
300 to 400 now okay and so I think
they're about all paid for okay and so
your part is a half million dollars give
or take
okay possibly yeah something like that
are they Distributing income to you guys
no so you've not seen a dime out of it
he runs it all the money comes back into
his management fees and nothing goes
back out to you guys at all and so all
you have is this Phantom thing that's
happening over here and you have
absolutely no control over how old is
your grandmother
she is in her 80s late 80s oh
and she has no Authority anymore she
just simply gave it to all seven of you
and she stepped out or does she have any
say in anything
I tried to involve her one time and um
she they kind of just brushed her off on
me I think she's
old enough to the point where
um
you're not
um hyper assertive as a matter of fact
you're on the other end of the assertive
scale is your husband an assertive
person
he's more assertive than I am yes okay
because here's you know you've got three
options
as I can see it
and then you need to decide on one of
these three and then quit worrying about
it drop it
okay okay option number one is continue
what you're doing and just let your
brother run it and just forget it and
not not think another thing about it and
someday they'll need your signature
okay okay and whatever just don't worry
about it okay I don't like that option
you don't like that option that's why
you called but that is an option okay
another option uh is uh scorched Earth
and that is uh you and your husband sit
down with your brother
uh call him for an appointment if he
won't give you one then you're gonna
have to write him a certified letter and
your husband can do the talking and you
say here's what it sounds like we have
tried repeatedly to get reports from you
to find out where the cash flow is going
from these properties you're not doing
anything and you say we don't trust you
you turn this into this it's not any of
that this business is being run very
poorly because the stakeholders are
getting no information this is an
improper way to run a business and we
want out and you're gonna buy us out
right now
and you're going to show us the
valuations and based on that you're
going to buy us out and if you do not do
that we're going to hire an attorney and
the circuit judge will force you to buy
us out we will disband this horrible
partnership that your grandmother put
together it's a nightmare
now that one sounds kind of fun the
downside is is that you probably lose
your brother in the process
right but you probably lost him anyway
because he's a turd
okay to an extent yeah no he is no he is
I mean there's no question about it I
mean he's a complete bully he has pushed
you into the corner and he's done that
since you were a tiny child and he's
continued to do it in your adulthood and
he gets away with it he's a turd okay no
question about it I mean you've told me
like five different ways you've
approached this guy and every time he
just stiff arms you and treats you with
complete disrespect and you know that's
true yeah
I like number two Dave and you haven't
gotten a number three yet yeah I'm
voting number number three is walk away
and call him and say I'm tired of this I
don't want anything else to do with it I
don't need the money I'm get prepare the
papers I'm going to sign them and indeed
you whatever it is and you can have it
all I don't want any of it screw you
I don't like that one Catherine this is
this is yours how much it is his I don't
like that one I I there's there's a part
of me doesn't like it but there's a part
of it that it's just life goes on
whatever it's not it's not her money
that's in it her grandmother gave it to
her it's not that it's not it's not it's
found money it's not the end of the
world it's just depends you know because
one way you keep your brother in the
thing I'm not sure you've got much when
you keep him that's what I'm saying but
um I think you take the bully on and the
bully caves he doesn't want to fight
he's just been pushing you away
and and no I'm not going to settle for
seeing the books now they were too late
we've that that that ship has sailed no
you cannot compromise yes you are buying
me out or the judge is going to tell you
to buy me out your decision you have 10
days
so that's a circuit court you'd have to
file a lawsuit to just the just to
dissolve this LLC
and you're a stakeholder in the LLC and
then they will have to bring forth
documents that show that you're in
violation of one of those and you're not
this is the you're filing for the
disillusionment of a partnership
he doesn't want that fight I don't think
you're losing anything with him
relationally either and and well you're
not going to be she talked she talks to
him now he won't talk to her again
exactly well maybe so I mean you know
you need your cut you need your cut
whatever yours is worth and you need to
see the books to get your Cut You Can Be
You Can Be You can no longer be
um any type of wishy-washy about this
you need to make a decision I'm going to
ignore it hold my nose and deal with it
that's the decision and I'm not going to
be stressed about it anymore and then
it's not anybody's fault but mine
because I made this decision to let
these people just run their course
that's one number two I'm going to take
it on full on frontal right at you we're
going to bring the Bazookas and we're
gonna burn this thing to the ground
number three uh we're just gonna walk
away and we're gonna hand you the keys
and you can keep it screw it I don't
need it
but make a decision The Angst of 12 or
10 years of you carrying all of this
relational garbage around this whole
deal it is it's been so destructive to
you and to your brother into your
relationship with him
it's a horrible deal
you need to get out of the deal one way
or another
emotionally
um
can I suggest that we sell all the
properties and and desolve it that way
well that's not your option the only
option you've got is they're going to
have to sell something to give you your
cut they may all want to stay together
except you
right you just want out so if they keep
going that's none of your business
right but you're out I want my cut you
need to sell off enough properties to
pay me my cut and you need to show me
proper valuation as to what my
one-seventh is and why and if you don't
give me proof of that we gonna talk to
the judge
okay and it's going to take two years
and twenty thousand dollars worth of
legal fees
oh yeah okay yeah the justice system has
nothing to do with Justice
or efficiency no not at all and so I
sure hope you don't get drug into that I
hope your brother's not that stupid but
he very well could be kind of sounds
like he is
so he didn't have time for a meeting
maybe he doesn't have time for a lawsuit
that's what I believe Dave I I think
that's why I don't have time for a
meeting and not new with his schedule
he'll do with anyone deal with her he
does not want to deal with her he's
stiff Army he doesn't want her input he
doesn't want her questioning how he's
doing things and I think this is an easy
out for the bully here he's gotten away
with it for too long he has I think this
is an easy out for him when she goes at
this he's gonna go all right to Jesus
yeah meeting he wants to he wants to get
done with this I think he's gonna yeah I
question out whether or not he's going
to show her the bookstore we get an
honest evaluation oh I can make him do
that too legally all right that's what I
would be I'm a stakeholder yeah I mean
the judge is going to get involved here
if he doesn't play yeah but this is
going to require tremendous like a 10x
assertiveness took for her and her
husband together off of what they have
done so far they're kind of like hey
would you please uh maybe it's like and
he's like nope okay sorry I asked yeah
you know good Lord yeah and the other
good news is you get out of a family
vacation which is always good
That's the Silver Lining here under all
this advice hey Grandma's out there
don't build stuff like this yeah seven
cousins it's crappy wow dumb butt idea
grandma
you're trying to be a blessing
you screwed this up it's like The
Walton's real estate fun good night Jim
Bob
not Mary Ellen no Mary Ellen you can't
see the bugs
huge swath of our audience has no idea
what we're even talking about right
there all right
this is the Ramsey chef